foreign
you ever thought about the International
Date Line I'm going to say that uh with
a great certitude no I have no
but it's kind of a weird place you know
you cry just one spot on Earth's surface
and it's then it's yesterday or tomorrow
right right and it's at the same time
but a different day yeah that's that's a
little creepy right it's a little weird
it is that's what you never thought
about that I you know because to me I
mean I get it that we're in motion and
so that's why there's got to be
different times but at I'm going to be
honest it's one of those things that I
never get right
and I'm talking about here on this
continent North America I'm not even
talking about leaving our Shores okay
you're talking about you don't get time
zones right
screw every single time zone up no
matter what email no even when they
explain it to me and then you guys still
screw it up so I think I have an
aversion for what it's worth what
prevents me from screwing it up is I
rederived time zones from first
principles almost every time I think of
them
so I say okay Earth is rotating west to
east the sun therefore Rises first for
everyone east of us so everyone east of
us has to be earlier
uh has to be later than us than the ones
west of us so I reconstruct that in my
head so that I get it right every time
for that
[Laughter]
valuable too that was valuable man that
is too much time thinking about time
okay so watch this so watch uh do you
remember who was the first to
circumnavigate the globe
um that was the man who went around the
World in 80 Days in that balloon
that's the that's exactly not the person
I'm talking about
so Ferdinand Magellan right okay this is
after Columbus and after a bunch of
other voyages to the new world from
Europe
uh he goes around the world and returns
to the port that they sailed from
okay and I think it was actually port in
Portugal but it doesn't matter for what
I'm about to describe so anyway so they
they leave Europe and they had
West
okay
there's a scribe on board named Antonio
pigafetta okay I think it was a wealthy
I think it was a wealthy nobleman who
was not part of the crew not he was just
went around joyriding basically okay but
he kept but he kept very good records
of what was going on well yeah that's
that's easy to do when you don't have
any work to do on the ship
exactly yeah so everybody else he's
lowering the boom and hoisting the
missing mass and you over there writing
brighten it down it's not lovely the way
you did that
again you show me that again
what a knot what a great knot what do
you call that like I'd like very much to
make a notation of that particular knot
that was basically what this guy did and
he kept track of who died on board
because disease would go through the
crew and at some point Magellan was
killed by by natives of on an island
that they arrived at and so Magellan did
not complete the voyage because he died
okay on route but the the ship made it
as so did Antonio pigafetta of course
you know Andrew's gonna make it you know
today I was extremely crestful and as
Magellan himself fell
to the ill will of some natives
however I shall Press On
all right so
so here's what happened so he goes west
and you keep track of what's called
local noon all right so when is noon
it's when the sun is at its highest
point in the sky okay okay oh and and
that's the middle of your day
and that whatever day that is and he's
marking these days on his calendar okay
and as they keep traveling he keeps
track and he's good at this okay he's an
wealthy educated Italian nobleman
and he's good at it okay
they come around the world
and come back he thinks it's Wednesday
and everyone there thinks it's Tuesday
huh he can't believe it he's and he's
writing uh I think they're pulling a
trick on me that they want to fool me
that they want to fool me then he went
to check other people and everyone says
it's Tuesday whatever day of the month
it was and he's still thinking it's
Wednesday and he said I kept very good
notes I don't know what happened here
and it's just sitting there in his
notebook
the confusion of a nobleman's scribe
and it is laid bare the discovery of the
need for an International Date Line
That's fascinating because there's no
need for it unless you're actually going
to make the trip yes
do you and I give him a rat's ass what's
in the center of the Pacific Ocean right
right it doesn't matter but if you're
gonna make the next trip you're gonna
make that trip you need to know it and
he discovered it by accident which I
thought was just so it's the kind of
things you discover when you're very
good at
when you're very careful in your
observations and in your data recording
yeah he was being a scientist without
even without even knowing it yeah and
then of course for weeks he still walked
around like come on man seriously what
day
seriously
it's Wednesday right come on how'd y'all
all get in on this
was it was it the King was it the king
because he said
he said would not give back right you
tell it to everybody
he pinned up a broad sheet in the center
of town and said don't tell anybody
exactly oh man that's funny so anyway
and of course if you go the other way
around the earth you would be you'd be a
day behind right so the point is if you
go west you're chasing the sun because
the sun sets in the west right right so
if you're going in the direction the sun
is and so you are adding a whole day to
your life as you go around that other
people are not enjoying and so so I'm
just I put it out there I don't know how
many people know that story but it's
it's it's in the notes of Magellan's
Voyage kept by Anton pigafetta it's
clearly there's no reason for there to
be bias in those observations that he
made he's just checking local noon
Sunrise Sunset and he's counting days
but in other places in his writings he
talks about there's a disease that
Afflicted the crew and and many of them
died and they had some natives from the
island that they befriended and came on
board
and when they did if you die on a ship
you know you know what to do with the
body
uh I would say bury it at Sea because
you know yeah they just toss it over not
yeah they're not very pleasant to be
around dead bodies yeah not on your
ships
as they're rotting next to your food
right exactly so you toss it overboard
and there he writes carefully and he
says oh and Natives and other
non-christians
floated face down and all the Christians
floated face up
towards heaven that's because this is
that's about how do you know what's in
their heart haha you don't know this but
guess what I was actually a Jewish
person there you go Mr Pink feta
yeah I converted yeah now why am I
floating the face up
so you know statistically I guess that
could have happened in that way or what
would your clothing do that but he was
deeply religious as were so many
um European explorers back then wanting
to convert the world to not simply
Christianity but Catholicism
specifically and and so this was a this
is also in his writings so basically if
you're going to evaluate the work of
someone who's an acute Observer right
you want to ask
could they have a bias of any kind
before you go into what it is they write
right and if he's deeply religious there
could be a religious bias you have to
watch for that but he's not going to
have a Tuesday Wednesday bias you don't
expect that exactly right right I'm just
saying it's really not very much of an
accomplishment for your particular deity
to allow your dead corpse uh there's no
other kind of court to float one way to
see the real deal would be like we threw
the Christians overboard and they
started to swim
well they pop back up
Praise Jesus
Jesus Jesus
wait or they never got sick in the first
place there you go that's even better
okay all right I'm not gonna say that
God favors you
are killing your ass at the same time
how do you know God loves you more than
me when you know your people die just
like my people my people float face up
well what is this soap what are we
talking about here we're talking about
soap what are you talking about they're
still dead they're dead I'm pretty sure
they would have thrown you overboard
whether or not you were dead let me tell
you something before we left court my
ass would have been thought
the kind of humor not accepted by at by
at the court gesture level right off
with his head they probably wouldn't let
me tell you something that probably
wouldn't have thrown me overboard they
would have tied a rope to my foot and
dragged me behind the ship
all right so that's everything you ever
knew wanted to know about the
International Date Line that is so cool
though by the way by the way we could
have put it anywhere in the world
but we had this convenient Pacific Ocean
which is one third of all the world's
longitude but it has to line up with the
prime meridian so that because it's the
opposite of the Prime Meridian and that
all worked out because Greenwich England
all right if you extend the line around
the other side of the earth it goes
right down the middle of the Pacific
Ocean and you got to avoid some islands
that are uh you don't want part of your
country to be on a different day so if
you watch you look at the if you look at
it it I think it has to accommodate
Hawaii it bends
it's got a little okay it's got a little
the little little you know some movement
because it's at the end of the day do
you really care what you know the
precise location on Earth yeah
especially the 24 times those are highly
fungible right I mean the the Eastern
time zone is not exactly where the line
would be you include the states that
want to be part of it yeah right right
and hardly anybody lives in the mountain
time zones
what I'm saying is that has the lowest
population right and so
it's also very narrow so I I don't know
if it's a TV uh schedulers whatever you
know they give the time and then the
slash Central Time right right so that
main time is East Coast West Coast and
then central time they don't get nobody
reports mountain time nobody reports
no because did you notice they don't
report mountain time they they they have
to adjust on their own who's there no
one's there that's why yes a few people
live in mountain time there are a few
people I know the same as like the
20-mile radius of Manhattan right but
still people live in mountain time the
same Montana Utah Colorado Arizona okay
New Mexico all right whatever
mountain time people send all your hate
mail to Chuck all right this mountain
time people get a new time zone there
you go and then we won't have to have
this conversation we won't be mad at me
I'm doing you a favor
thank you Chuck oh by the way a quick
one there was a TV show I forgot what
network was on Zack and Cody okay it was
like a like Nicholas yeah one of those
Disney they had an episode where they
uh they were on a ocean liner that
crossed the International Date Line and
it they turned it into like a like a
groundhog day uh reliving the the
incident thing so every time it went
across it's like the the ship flip back
and forth it reset and then they all the
events are happening again and they got
to replay it so people think magical
things happening there but it's a
completely arbitrary place where we put
it nice we could have put it right down
the middle of Manhattan if we wanted but
that would have just been weird I'll see
you next Tuesday yeah
that's a whole nother date line
I guess so very good chuck all right uh
we gotta and land this explainer Neil
deGrasse Tyson here thanks Chuck for
being there
your personal astrophysicist offering
yet another Star Talk explainer keep
looking up
ha
[Music]